cooking up Meals Ready for football VIPs
in a luxury Doha hotel that's seen the
World Cup transformation
with workers set to benefit from
protections and checks on conditions
this'll be the first time in the history
of a FIFA mega event that you'll have a
dedicated workers rights and labor
rights team deployed during the event
the interview workers to make sure that
they're taken care of we'll do that for
the stadiums
pre-pre-match we'll also do any of the
training sites and non-competition
venues as well this is the rigorous
audit Qatar wants the world to see and
to hear assurances migrant workers are
gaining more rights with freedoms to
move jobs a minimum wage and living and
working conditions safer and more
comfortable the confidence that I have
is that the systems have been deployed
and if there are issues that do well or
there will arise which will likely arise
no doubt that we have a system that will
deploy and enforce those regulations
immediately and not everyone feels
exploited
life can be tough but it's got better
sir weekly six days one day off one day
hundreds of thousands of workers come to
Qatar not to enjoy the country
necessarily but because they know the
pay is better than at home and to send
it home
salary means all basic salary thousand
bills 230 pounds is the guaranteed
monthly pay
in a country that spent more than a
hundred billion pounds on infrastructure
in the lead-up to the World Cup
in Qatar the disparities can be Stark
even within the low paid labor force
largely from South Asia
that accommodation provided for workers
at the hotel we visited there is talk of
bed bugs and cockroaches but they are
happy unlike stories they hear from
elsewhere guys
yeah has he complained yeah
maybe one double bid one down one up
like this the suffering and deaths of
workers will forever stay in this
tournament with concerns raised by
England and Wales
but the World Cup has changed Qatar this
is a Statewide program that the
government Ministry of Labor will
continue onwards after we're uh where
we're done with the with the final
events an event that can seem Out Of
Reach for the low-paid workers relied on
to deliver this world cup the Stars will
never see the grittiness beyond the
glamor Rob Harris Sky News Doha